hey what's going on folks I want to give
you guys a real quick sneak peek of the
next giveaway and like I said in my
previous videos I'm going to give away
any Game of Thrones season of your
choice on January 1st and after I mail
that out the next giveaway will be this
game of Thrones t-shirt I haven't
ordered a shirt yet that way I can get
the right size for whoever wins and I
will pay for the shirt and just have
this shirt directly mailed to your house
that way you don't have to wait for it
to get mailed to me then me mail it out
to you and all you have to do to get a
chance to win either one of these gifts
is subscribe to this channel and you get
two entries if you were already a
subscriber also can you guys do me a
favor and like the videos too I hate
asking you guys to do that but it does
actually help widen the audience just
click the thumbs up button I would
really appreciate that alright now let's
get stuff started and I have some new
and interesting information for you guys
today last night I received a message
that contained a revised version of the
plot leaked and I'm not sure where it
actually came from someone may have done
this on their own or the original leaker
may have released the rest of the leak
that they you know may have been holding
back either way it's all still up for
debate and we can certainly discuss it
in the comment section afterwards but
you remember how the original plot leaks
seemed like there was some missing
scenes well this one has all the
original scenes for each episode but it
also has almost all of the blanks filled
in that can give you a clearer picture
of what's going to take place if you
want to believe it but I got to be
honest with you this sounds a hell of a
lot cooler than it originally did and if
all this would happen to come true this
would probably have to be the biggest
leak of all time but anyways let's get
started season 7 episode 1 is titled
winter episode 1 opens up to the White
Walkers marching south we see an undead
polar bear in a nice spider being ridden
by a white Walker brain and mirror have
been allowed through the wall and they
have a scene with Edie Edie tells bran
that John is at Winterfell when king of
the north bran doesn't tell wed about
John's parentage but he tells Mirror
about it afterwards Mira then tells
brand that her father hinted that
Rhaegar and Lyanna loved each other
John Sansa Davos Lyanna torment in a
leased car starker at the high table
discussing what to do with the castle's
car hold dreadfort and last hearth leona
wants two castles to go to the loyal
houses who helped John but at least once
John to forgive the children of the
Karstarks and numbers John does this but
lets the wildlings take control of the
dreadfort
Arya frees ed mirror from the phrase
sells admir is depressed after getting
the blackfish killed
however Arya tells him to retake
Riverrun as the phrase are dead and with
that she leaves him
Tyrion tells the sand snakes that he's
disgusted that they murdered his own
niece and that after Danny takes the
throne they're going to pay and near the
coast of Dorne
Yara's forces Tyrell and Martell and
Danny split up yours fleet is headed
towards the Iron Islands and Danny's is
heading towards Dragonstone and Euron
builds his thousand ships and head south
jaime and cersei get into an argument
Cersei manages to get Jaime to forgive
her and they start having sex Brienne
arrives at Winterfell after seeing the
stark banners Melisandre and the
Brotherhood without banners run into
each other Melisandre tells them about
how John is azure high and the
Brotherhood without banners decide to go
to Winterfell and Jorah arrives in old
town Jamie and the Lannister army leave
King's Landing to go south and sack
Highgarden Jamie takes widow's wail with
him in the episode ends when Danny
arrives at Dragonstone Tyrion and Danny
go into Stannis's old war council and
Danny says shall we begin
season 7 episode 2 is titled blood and
steal episode opens up to Jon receiving
a message from Tyrion asking all the
Lords of the north to go to Dragonstone
and swear fealty to Queen Daenerys John
and Davos decide to go as Tyrion
mentioned she had dragons and dragon
stone had dragon glass John leaves Sansa
in control of the north and says goodbye
to ghost John and Davos along with a few
Northman head to white Harbor
you're on ambushes Yara's fleet and
after a few minutes of battle yara saves
Theon's life however yara is captured
tyrion convinces dani to not use her
dragons to take King's Landing as most
of the people who would die would be
innocent
Jamie arrives at horn Hill and convinces
randyll Tarly to bend the knee by
letting house Tarly become the warden of
the south Jorah goes to the citadel and
find Sam who finds out that dragonglass
is the cure for greyscale john and davos
arrive at white harbor and take ships to
Dragonstone and brandon mirror leave
Castle black on horseback heading
towards Winterfell Jaime bran and
Randall began laying siege to Highgarden
aurilla attacks Melisandre however
before Arya kills Melisandre she tells
Arya that she didn't kill Gendry den
jury sneaks past some gold cloaks and
steals Robert's Warhammer as all the
Baratheon czar dead ginjury considered
King Tommen to be a Baratheon
Cersei finds out the Warhammer was
stolen but she doesn't care however
Cersei finds out she's pregnant after
Qyburn examines her the tyrell forces
surrender in betray Olenna Tyrell and
the episode ends with Elena telling
Jaime that she killed Joffrey and Alanna
then poisoned herself dying in front of
Jamie
season 7 episode 3 titled Ice and Fire
episode opens up with Jon arriving at
Dragonstone and meeting Tyrion on the
beach they shake hands and talk about
Daenerys Arya has a dream and rides up
the river to find Nymeria Dany is
watching her dragons fly when Jon
approaches her Danny tells John to bend
the knee however he doesn't and asks her
to send her dragons north to help fight
the White Walkers she doesn't believe
him but Tyrion tells Danny that Jon
isn't crazy and that he should be heard
out Euron captures the sand snakes and
olaria your own kills Obara since she
was annoying him your own forces lady
named
Nym to take off her clothes and start
touching herself you're on then poisons
tyene enforces ilaria to watch after
that he drowns ilaria for the drowned
God and tells the Ironborn that there's
going to be an even more glory after he
takes the reach into western lands Jaime
returned to King's Landing and Cersei
tells him she's pregnant
Jaime tell Cersei that Tyrion did not
kill Joffrey Jorah leaves Oldtown to
Dragonstone
after hearing Dany was there so he says
goodbye to Sam
Tyrion and davos come up with a plan to
meet up with Jaime to discuss terms of
Cersei surrender
Dany and John are talking on a beats
when she asked him to pet drogon what
she does
then Theon lands on the shore of
Dragonstone which he runs into john who
tells him that if he didn't help Sean
John would have killed him
Theon tells Danny that you're on
captured Yara and took control of his
sister's fleet the Brotherhood without
banners arrived at wonderful to find out
John is not there in the Hound and
Brienne meet again
however torment interrupts them Tyrion
and Davos leave Dragonstone for King's
Landing
to talk with Jaime and that's when the
episode ends with bran and Arya looking
at Winterfell from different locations
or he is on a horse with Nymeria at her
side season 7 episode 4 titled reunion
Sansa is out praying in the godswood
when Arya and bran the Hound is carrying
brand arrived Tyrion and davos arrive at
King's Landing where bran and Jaime come
out to negotiate bran and Tyrion catch
up quickly
however Jaime refuses to surrender
ginger eSports Davos and the gold cloaks
Saul Tyrion so they follow them back to
their boat where Kendra takes out the
gold cloaks with his hammer and go with
Tyrion in Davos back to Dragonstone
Jorah arrives on Dragonstone and
reunites with Danny Jon offers Jorah
Longclaw but Jorah declines the offer
Jon gets a message from Sansa telling
him that Arya and bran are alive and at
Winterfell
Littlefinger tell Sansa he'll send the
veil forces home if she doesn't marry
him Qyburn creates a weapon of some sort
that will slay dragons and says that the
Meister were the ones who defeated the
Dragons last time they came to Westeros
Davos and Tyrion returned to Dragonstone
with ginjury until Danny that Cersei
won't surrender
Gendry tells John he knew Arya and John
tells him Arya is at Winterfell the
episode ends with Davos and John coming
up with a plan to get Danny's forces
north and they decide they're going to
capture a white season 7 episode 5
titled the field of fire
John Davos Gendry and Jorah about to
head north when fian asked if he can
join them as a way of getting John to
forgive him and John allows him to join
Danny splits her armies into two groups
on solid into three key and marches to
King's Landing randyll Tarly and Jamie
take Kai burns weapon that's used for
dragons and leave King's Landing to
battle the Dothraki with the reach in
western forces Brienne and Arya spar and
Winterfell with ghost - Nymeria watching
mirror tells bran that she's going to
leave Winterfell to go back home into
Hound tell sands of that Littlefinger
portrayed her father and Sansa comes up
with a plan to take revenge against
Littlefinger Sansa agrees to marry a
little finger make an aria angry with
her and the scene cuts away before Sansa
tells Arya about her plan Sam finds out
that John's real name is Aegon and
leaves old town before Euron can sack
the place the Brotherhood without
banners leave Winterfell and head
towards the wall along with Tommen and
Brienne as Thoreau's has a vision of a
battle in the snow beyond the wall the
first battle between the Queens begin
reach forces are defeating unsullied
forces due to randyll Tarly commanding
archers whom have the Sun at their back
Dothraki forces collide with Lena
Lannister forces nearby bran kills two
Dothraki and Jaime kills one Jamie seems
to be winning the battle until drogon
and Rey gall appear ray gall kills
Randall and dick
Tarly with dragon fire Chi burns weapon
injures ragel however drug on destroys
the weapon and drove on nearly kills
Jamie however bran saves him in the
episode ends with Jamie arriving back at
King's Landing and telling Cersei that
she should surrender but she refuses and
sits on the Iron Throne season 7 episode
6 the undead Jon Snow Jorah Theon Gendry
and Davos arrive at Castle black edie
and Jon Snow reunite Ned tells him
others arrived earlier that day
Brotherhood without banners with torment
and Brienne ginjury forgives Thoreau's
and barrack for selling him to
Melisandre berry tells everyone that
John is a Zora hi and torment and Davos
agree John tells the Nights Watch and
Brotherhood without banners his plan to
capture a white Davos stays behind at
Castle black and writes a message to
Danny saying if she comes north John
will lay down his title of King in a
North John and Davos give them
dragonglass from dragon stone and the
Nights Watch wildlings and Brotherhood
without banners head north of the wall
and after a few minutes of screen time
they run into a lone white the Hound
attempts to tie down the white however
the white flees causing the group to
chase it down the group corner the white
between a cliff a frozen lake in the
woods which were they were emerging from
the white jumps off the cliff and we see
hundreds of whites climbing the cliff no
one sees the whites on the cliff however
several hundred White's emerge from the
woods and pin the group at the edge of
the cliff forests and Bendrick ignite
their swords in the battle begins the
whites whom climbed the cliff made it to
the top and attacked the group from
behind it is killed along with several
other Nights Watch members White Walkers
emerge from the woods one of them is
riding a nice spider for us is killed
brutally by an undead polar bear the
helm tries to save him but is unable to
in a white Walker with dual blades
fights John and kills John with a sword
in the gut Brienne kills a white Walker
with Oathkeeper
Jorah retrieves lone call from John's
Dead's body and a Brotherhood without
banners member kills a white Walker with
the arrow withdraw
glass Gendry smashes a whites face with
his Warhammer the night's king gets off
his undead horse and fights beric whom
has a flaming sword
berrak is disarmed and mortally wounded
in ten seconds but still alive before
the night's king kills barrack Danny
arrives on drag on with Vasari on
Rhaegar was wounded earlier this season
drove on and Viserion killed several
whites allowing the group to escape back
to the wall The Hound subdues a white
and takes it with him a white Walker
throws a massive spear and drogue on
injuring him and causing him to fly away
the night's king shocked this area on
before driving an a sword through his
eye
killing Vasari on berry crawls over to
John's body and gives him the kiss of
life earlier this season Melisandre
tells barrack that John is azor Ahai and
dies
John has revived picks up barracks
flaming sword and slays a few whites
before he gets injured and disarmed and
before the white kills John again benjin
shows up and kills several whites with
his flaming sachet before dismounting
benjin carries John and puts him on his
horse and whispers goodbye nephew as
John is running away he helplessly
watches as benjin is surrounded by
whites and John passes out at the end of
the episode the night's king resurrects
Vasari on the episode cuts away as we
see vissarion's blue eyes season 7
episode 7 the wall the episode opens up
as John returns to Castle black and is
greeted by tor maan who thought he was
dead
The Hound tells John he caught a white
and John tells Davos to wait a message
to all the kings queens and Lords and
Westeros to assemble a Great Council at
the dragon pit John tells Danny that
Viserion was killed and she says she'll
burn every last white Walker in white
Jorah hands John back Longclaw telling
him it's his they leave Castle black and
head to King's Landing Sam and Gilly
arrive at Winterfell just in time for
sanz's wedding to Littlefinger Arya is
not at the wedding but bran is when the
wedding night arya takes off her mask
she's wearing sanz's face in the season
5
finale we learned that you don't have to
be dead in order to have a mask in Oriya
kills Littlefinger with a knife in the
mouth
Cersei finds out that she had a
miscarriage in Qyburn tells her that
there has been a call for a great
counsel she allows for them to have
entry to the city due to Jaime's counsel
bran tell Sam that John's parents are
Liana and Rhaegar Sam tells brain that
somehow that someone named Aegon
Targaryen was born at the Tower of joy
Brandon has a flashback of a wedding
between Rhaegar and Lyanna stark Sansa
manages to prevent the armies of the
Vale from leaving thanks to Robin Arryn
and bronze yon John and Danny arrive at
King's Landing after a meeting between
Jamie and Tyrion Euron has already
arrived
most of the main cast are at this
location Jon Snow Cersei Jaime Tyrion
Davos bran you're on Theon ginjury Dany
the Hound the mountain Brienne Podrick
Varys grey worm a sand a chi barn and
hormann are all present at the dragon
pit scene and the Hound brings up the
caged white Jon enters the centre of the
area and tells the Lords of Westeros
that the only way to kill these
creatures is with fire so Cersei tests
this and orders the mountain to kill the
white the mountain cuts it into pieces
however it's still moving John asked for
all the Lords to send their armies with
to battle these creatures Jaime agrees
with John and says he'll help along with
several others including Cersei and
Euron and afterwards there's a scene
between Theon and you're on your own
tells Dion that his sister's dead and
feeling vows to get revenge and there's
another scene in Tyrion tell Cersei that
he did not kill Joffrey and Cersei tells
him that she already found out Jaime
told her that alehna killed Joffrey in
episode 3 and after John and the others
lead the city
Cersei tells Jaime that she was lying
back there and hopes that her enemies
destroy each other
Jamie however is disgusted and he takes
the Lannister army and heads north with
Brienne and on the ship heading back to
dragonstone John and Danny have sex
after Jon comforts her after the death
of vissarion
and at the end of the episode the
night's king uses magic to destroy the
wall the same one he used
to get into the three-eyed Ravens cave
in the scene cuts once the night's king
mounts Vissarion in major deaths in
season 7 or yara Greyjoy glorious and
tyene sand oberus an Elena Tyrell
randyll Tarly dick and Tarly Thoris of
meer Jon Snow who's resurrected dolorous
EDD beric Dondarrion Viserion to White
Walkers Benjen stark and Petyr Baelish
Wow now that's a hell of a lot of
information definitely a lot more than
the original plot lake and some of that
is pretty damn interesting still not
sure what to believe or not have to see
if any more evidence comes out to
support any of this new stuff that's in
here but I read it over and it sounded
pretty interesting a lot more
interesting than what it said back in
October so I'm kind of curious to get
your guys thoughts on some of this stuff
so comment below and tell me what you
think about this anyways I'll see you
guys later bye